I have to own my size
I can't go and be like well I want to
trade my body and I want to be smaller
like not going to work right now I'm six
foot eight and about 400 pounds
my name is Brian Shaw and I'm the world
Strongest Man the heaviest I would
compete is about 420 pounds what do you
have to do to maintain that eating lies
to be honest it's a lot of you gotta
have the peanut butter
I'll buy at least close to ten pounds if
not more than me end up pretty much
buying everything they have you know on
typical day I'm probably be consumed at
the very low end five to six thousand
calories a day and then the upper end
would be about ten thousand a day
we saw that video of you going through
the aisle on the plane yep
are there any moments like that on in
day to day that you have to deal with it
does happen fitting different places and
it can be challenging I find it a little
bit hard when things are tiny
I definitely like my utensils to be
bigger my wife and I have different
spoons we have different Forks that we
use because my fingers are so big typing
is a little bit harder you kind of learn
to adapt to it because they're not going
to make a keyboard bigger just for me
the reason I actually sit like a lot in
these folding chairs is because a lot of
office chairs have arms on them you know
and I can't fit my hips because you can
see I'm kind of off of this chair so
that's what works
do people that kind of look at you and
be like why is it huge guys a lot of
people do look it's kind of funny
because I don't really notice it anymore
I like being big I've kind of embraced
it I've always been able to do stuff
with my body whether is playing
basketball or strongman or you know
really anything but it's it's a positive
thing too